what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we just watched Loki
episode three and there is so much to
digest and break down in this one
episode alone we are going to do this
over a few different videos but starting
with this video we want to talk about
how o b could actually be a villain but
Victor timely could actually be good OB
being a villain is actually a theory
that has been going on since the very
first episode and now it looks like
things are tying together that does
seemingly Point towards that theory that
Obi could be a villain still working for
he who remains in fact he could be the
key in helping he who remains return
however he needs Victor timely in order
to do it now you might be thinking but
he who remains is dead and yes he is but
keep in mind in the comics King has the
ability to transfer his Consciousness
into other different variants and he did
this using his own technology in the
Comics so it wasn't like a supernatural
process that Kang used or a power that
he tapped into he simply built the
technology that enabled him to do that
he would switch his Consciousness
transfer his mind to an alternate body
right as he died and let's not forget
the last thing he said to Sylvie before
he died in the season finale of Loki he
said see you soon now some people think
that he was simply talking about his
variance and of course that would make
sense but what if he wasn't what if he
was literally meaning he himself would
see Sylvie too because he would be
returning some insiders have stated that
he who remains is going to indeed show
up in Loki season 2 and some insiders
have even thrown out the name he who
returns and this episode made it very
clear that he who remains had a plan and
we have a good theory of what this plan
could actually be and it involves OB in
this episode we meet Victor timley a
variant of Nathaniel Richards who was
the original King the Conqueror now keep
in mind this is not the same origin that
he who remains had he who remains was
not Victor timely who was given a TVA
book remember the season finale of Loki
where he who remains explained all of
the different variants the multiversal
war and basically his origin I truly do
believe that Victor timely is a good
variant here's why and here's why their
Origins are completely different
remember what he who remains said he
said eons ago in the third 31st Century
so keep that in mind even though it was
forever ago for he who remains it was
still in the future to us to the main
MCU timeline the 31st century is the
3000s so he who remains as origin
started in the late 2900s and the early
3000s so definitely not 1868 plus
remember he who remains said when
describing the origin that this was
before the TVA so his origin was before
the TVA had even been built into
existence yet now that is obviously very
different for Victor timley obviously
the TVA exists if somebody RN Slayer
gave him a TVA handbook and in this
version of Victor timely's life on this
different timeline he doesn't create the
TVA not directly so his origin is very
different than he who remains in
probably a lot of the other kings out
there but it doesn't come as that big of
a surprise because this is the
Multiverse not only can variance of one
person exist in a different universe but
they can exist at a different time and
that's what we are experiencing here but
he who remains had a very specific plan
he told Miss minuts and then RNs Slayer
to deliver the TVA guide book to this
specific King variant Victor timley in
1868 now why would he do that and what
is his plan well I believe his plan is
simply to return and I believe that OB
is helping him do that of course along
with mis minutes Ren Slayer is kind of
kept kept in the dark at this point in
time but we do know thanks to earlier
episodes that she was basically a high
Commander for him in the multiversal war
so I'm sure she'll play some type of
part in he who remains as return however
right now there is kind of one thing
holding up this plan keeping it from
happening and that is the possible
destruction of the TVA and everyone
inside of it including OB and he who
remains already built the TVA he doesn't
want to have to do it again probably for
whatever reason that hopefully will be
revealed if this is accurate he who
remains needed to ditch the body and the
position that he was in and get into a
new one now we know that in the comics
Kang isn't really Immortal there's only
one version of Kang that is Immortal and
that is granted to him he is not
naturally Immortal he is a human yes his
suit and Technology do allow him to live
longer but he isn't Immortal so perhaps
he simply just needed a new body to
continue to reain everything but in
order to get a new body he would need a
new variant of himself self and in order
to get a new variant of himself the
sacred timeline had to split it had to
essentially turn into the Multiverse
that would mean that everything that
happened in the finale of Loki season 1
was planned which makes sense because
we're talking about he who remains here
the person who built the TVA who has
been essentially writing time you know
this person has a plan and everything
that he does is intentional and we know
that he led Loki and Sylvie to him so
now the Multiverse exists again it's not
just one Universe not just one timeline
so variants of him exist now ones that
he could transfer his Consciousness into
and it looks like he picked a variant
that isn't really a main King we've seen
the other main Kings we've seen am
mortise we have seen ramut the Scarlet
Centurion we've seen scroll that are
King Victor timley is very different
it's almost like he's just a body for he
who remains to take over and who right
now is helping preserve the Multiverse
OB OB is making sure that the time Lo
can actually handle all of the different
strands of time he said many times
already that he needs to basically
retrofit a device that can keep the time
Loom intact to be able to handle all of
these different timelines so basically
he needs to expand its capacity is what
he said so OB is literally helping keep
the Multiverse intact because if it was
simply just one Universe then only one
king would exist and keep in mind the
timeline started to branch and the
Multiverse started to be formed before
he he who remains was killed remember he
who remains suddenly felt the Multiverse
began to exist again he said so I fibbed
I don't know what's going to happen next
and as he said this the timeline started
to Branch so Victor timley could have
existed before he died that way when he
did die he could transfer his
Consciousness to him eventually or he
could have transferred it to another
person however they specifically need
Victor timely because one he is not a
very Advanced King in fact he isn't King
at all he is simply Victor timley and
this is not a Victor timley who was
Nathaniel Richards before was ratat
before was the Scarlet Centurion and
then did go back to Earth at some point
in time and became Victor timley that is
not how it is that's how it was in the
comics but not how it is in this new MCU
story in this story Victor timley was
born Victor timley and he didn't invent
anything without the help of one of his
other variants he who remains giving him
the TVA handbook however this was
specific I think because he exists in a
time where the technology he needs to
create everything just isn't there and
he even says that in this episode so he
gives him just enough to make him know
what the TVA is and create some sort of
a device that could help OB when he gets
to the TVA this episode was really about
Victor timley going back to his home and
grabbing that one specific device and
what if this was specifically he who
remains his plan he who remains
transferred his Consciousness into a
different variant but then had Mis
minutes and raavana Rin Slayer give
Victor timley the TVA handbook so he
could create a specific device so he
would eventually go back at this very
point in time in the TVA when it's about
to explode then give that device to OB
he fixes the Tim Loom so it can handle
the capacity of all of the different
time streams and then bam the real he
who remains can return later on in the
future he could take Victor timely
however I think his Consciousness would
have already been transferred at this
point in time I do believe Victor timley
is good sure he may be a little bit of a
scammer selling prototypes to people
that don't necessarily work but we know
that he's not a conqueror and he showed
many signs of being a good person in
fact in the scene where he sold the
temporal Loom there was the one man who
tried to buy it from him but he was
outbid that man then went to the bar and
he put his hat on the bar and after
Victor timley had sold the device he
went over to that man and gave him some
money secretly he put it under his hat
he gave him little pat on the shoulder
showing that he was sorry and he felt
bad for him I don't think this is King
the Conqueror at all we know that
variants can be completely different
from each other look at Sylvia and Loki
so I think Victor timley is good and I
think he could be eventually a really
good Ally for Loki and Mobius and as far
as OB being a villain I've heard some
theories that he could be a king variant
however I don't think this is
necessarily true because if that were
true his temporal Aura would work for
the TVA but it doesn't that's why they
need Victor timley however I do believe
that he who remains is getting the help
from OB because remember OB wrote the
TVA guide book but he who remains
created the TVA so he who remains and OB
had to be very very close and OB
probably played a massive role in
helping create the TVA and of course
maintain it over these eons so I'm
betting that he who remains if he had a
plan asked OB to help and OB since he's
known him for so long and knows him to
be the creator of the TVA and has helped
him throughout this entire process well
I'm sure OB is going to take his side
but that is just my theory on this let
me know what do you think about this do
you think OB is bad do you think Victor
timley is good let us know all of your
thoughts and your theories in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news also
don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment cuz then you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
you can also find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof